ça peut être complexes à appliquer une
mesure semblable donc c'est pour ça que
c'est important de voir ce qu'il soit
écrit dans le décret notre attitude
c'est de dire on va rendre sa facile au
lieu de donner des constats d'infraction
nos inspecteurs randonnée découvre
visage bombay c'est demain le port du
masque qui va être obligatoire dans les
transports en commun partout au québec
pour tous les passagers de 12 ans et
plus et j'en parle avec l'homme que vous
venez de voir d'ailleurs à l'écran
philippe schnobb le président du conseil
d'administration de la stm la société
transport de montréal bonjour monsieur
nov
bonjour alors le port du masque
obligatoire dès demain sur l'ensemble du
réseau mais vous ne donnerez pas d'âme
en expliquez moi comment vous allez
appliquer ça dès le départ avait été
mentionné dans l'annoncé a été faite le
qui aurait pas de coercition à ce niveau
là toi demande donc c'était pas prévu
toute façon nous en a dit on va prendre
la proche de sensibilisation on va faire
répéter le message ceux qui prennent le
métro de d aujourd'hui vous avez
commencé à voir des affiches un peu
partout qui rappelle que c'est la
nouvelle consigne on va le répéter dans
les bus ce sera écrit à l'avant des bus
ce sera écrit dans le bus le chauffeur
de bus propres appuyer sur un bouton
pour faire passer un message pour
rappeler aux gens que c'est la consigne
est on voit surtout distribué des
masques on en a déjà vu et 235 mille
couvrir visage
en juin on va continuer on reprend la
distribution demain ça va se faire dans
des stations de métro en après midi
la semaine prochaine on alterne semaine
c'est l'après midi une semaine c'est
l'avant midi si vous voulez avoir la
liste des stations où on fait ça c'est à
stm point est fausse et c'est trés
détail on va le faire aussi sur
certaines lignes de bus plus achalandée
donc l'idée c'est sensibilisation
distribution va avoir distribué un
million et demi de couvre visage d'ici
la rentrée
là on se dit plus les gens vont voir
avoir accès à sa puce a déjà fonctionné
parce que on est passé de 0 % port de
couvre visage ou à peu près là au mode
mais plus on est rendu à peu près 60% si
on se fie aux observations visuelles qui
ont été faites dans le métro donc ça a
quand même eu des résultats depuis ce
qu'on a fait jusqu'à c'est sur la bonne
volonté à des gens qui
voudront à votre avis porter le masque
mais on sait quand même que le port du
duc ouvreur visage ça fait pas
l'unanimité qu'est ce que vous allez
faire contre les récalcitrants s'ils
sont nombreux où même s'il y en a
quelques-uns qu'est ce que vous allez
faire à l'instinct province parce que je
vous ai dit on va distribuer découvre
visage quelqu'un n'aurait pas dans le
métro ils les agents station va en avoir
mais en cas de refus la source citée par
exemple moi je pense que les gens vont
devoir s'habituer ça va devenir
obligatoire ou ici dans les endroits
publics fermés à montréal
alors si vous n'avez pas de masque
support entre l épicerie où elle a fermé
six parce que vous voulez pas porter de
masque
peut-être que les gens vont se rendre
compte qu'il faut qu'ils mettent un peu
de lest dans leur conviction parce que
il remporte pas prendre le bus ou le
métro c'est une chose pour pouvoir
contrer les pistes en est une autre
là je pense que ça va aider ce règlement
doivent être appliquées à montréal
et si lui ou si le vendeur du québec ça
va inciter les gens à jouer je pas le
porter pasqua c'est très important que
tout le monde contribue à cette mesure
là de notre point de vue c'est une façon
de rassurer les gens les gens sont
inquiets les gens pensent qu'on peut
être contaminée dans le transport
collectif il ya est-ce le cas ou non la
question n'est pas là il faut rassurer
les gens doivent amener les jeunes en
transport collectif parce que je pense
pas que la solution soit de retourner
chacun dans sa voiture oui c'est pas il
ya beaucoup moins de monde qui utilisent
le transport en commun qu'auparavant
qu'avant la pandémie gré par ailleurs
qu'il ya beaucoup moins de monde en
général dans les transports les gens
vont pas travailler
c'est clair propre avis vaut pas plus en
voiture si on traverse il et on voit la
congestion sur l'épaule mater montréal
est pour beaucoup de congestion donc les
gens sont pas nécessairement dans leur
auto ça c'est sauter mais si on retourne
oui vous avez certainement vu ce qui
s'est passé en france cet épisode
tragique un chauffeur d'autobus qui a
demandé à des usagers de porter le
masque et il a été
violente et il en est même décédé
vendredi vous de votre côté vous n'avez
pas l'intention de demander au chauffeur
d'autobus de vérifier le port du masque
j'ai prêté jeu prévu cette nouvelle
halle puis c'est très regrettable
évidemment c'est clair que on va
intervenir s'il ya des gestes violents
qui sont posés la question pologne
on va sensibiliser les gens portent des
masques mais s'il ya des gestes violents
c'était autre chose complètement la loya
nos inspecteurs de la police pour faire
respecter la loi n'a pas le droit de
frapper les gens c'est clair j'espère
qu'on ne faut pas qu'on aille au delà de
cette norme sociale tout le monde doit y
contribuer à rassurer les gens tout le
monde doit le porter et jusqu'à présent
comme je vous l'aï dit on est passé de
zéro pour cent soixante pour cent de
porc dans le métro d'après les
observations visuelles sans même que
l'obligation soit en vigueur on a bon
espoir de pouvoir atteindre un niveau
assez élevé des gens en confiance je
fais confiance aux gens très bien alors
on verra bien comment ça va se passer
c'est le jeune homme merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous au revoir